oh wow welcome to this video very strong
opponent Grand Master dashi Kieran from
India can look it up here krishna and
asha kiran is about 2,700 rated rated
maybe slightly lower I don't know but
very strong GM um let's see I can play
my my three lines see what happens I
have beaten him once with a 5d takes it
high I remember that okay on this is six
hmm I can still like it Bishop g5 let's
see if he goes a 6 a-6 and b5 this is
very often an offbeat option in the
Kings Indian that that it's not too bad
I came to shove d3 it's always tricky
decision do you want to get the bishop
to c 2 i'm going to keep it only tomb
okay I'm not quite sure that looks like
as I know it does not look right to me
with all due respect 90 to be five
before not sure I can also go a for
simply he opens up the C file I know
that this very often is a good source of
counter play for black but mostly when
I'm committed to castling long which I'm
not really here okay is g3 a move I do
that f5 this night h4 so this is not on
and at least that thing weird i'm
intending just to play 92 backend kick
this piece away so 92 f 5 I can take so
this is not possible it probably has to
return now
yeah what can I say black black is
strategically almost possible sit here
but of course you will will be a bit
tricky so each form that's not really
helpful before night everything's
everything's nice I wonder okay not sure
about before really yeah I'm not sure
Sam it's very nice this position but of
course still tricky
is is trying to to speed up here
understandably I'm dumber and down and
down long time am so let's see this is
this is hanging here maybe should really
protect it yeah it is unclear now I have
haven't played it in the best possible
way obviously how to how to play now
this is not a not a good piece placement
unfortunately okay maybe I need to I
need to jettison this H phone it should
have one was very passive I need to
coordinate PCM kini to a Scott Bishop g4
yeah that's a bit of a shame yeah I
really miss played that G position after
move 15 or 16 years I mean if I get this
in the tournament game every time i'll
be on 2600 in no time really it was
totally totally bad for black I came it
does not help
don't get any of that i can now regroup
time maybe you can do something on f2
that's possible of course he's got a
huge time advantage check
check
I can take you for yeah but 40 seconds
is really too little in this in this
some in this position and I got this you
got the discovered discovered moves
and queen g2 yeah let him play 90 to 110
on Jack or this one yeah yeah that's a
bit of a shame resigns that's a bit of a
shame really yeah this disposition is
just totally totally crazy bad for luck
I just need to be precise which I wasn't
starting with Roxy one maybe so maybe I
should play age for him it's not not so
not so easy to determine the best way
the reason why this is totally bad for
blackest I mean the queenside is already
busted yeah but a four a five this is
this is weak and cannot ever move so the
queenside I'm already winning and he
does not have anything on the kingside
going I can play G 4-h form 22 to stop
this and Roxy one was just bad I wasn't
playing this determinedly enough I need
to play just g4 edge for him I thought I
could maybe go play this without the
pawn moves but Roxy one has the problem
that it also leaves a five undefended so
he could later play Queen d8 with the
tempo if I just go g4 h4 here this this
is this is an unplayable position for
black really no matter what is rated I
mean I'm threatening h5 here and if I
can get this in and winning really it's
not like an advantage so you must play
at 5pm and then I just take this twice
something like this look g1 this is a
ruin simply the computers on 1.5 which
is pretty conservative probably probably
that that's more even but yeah it's
still it's very murky of course though
this is this was this wasn't right
I mean white is still better no no
question still a 1.5 according to the
comp but takes takes takes yeah this
this is bad I really underestimated F
for him I need to take you know but
still plus 2 if you want to believe the
comp now something like this ambush of
age 6 this is not at all playable yeah
that's a total total ruin yeah and this
is this is this is really really bad
really bad yeah I underestimated that my
pieces I really tied up him this here
black is ok probably yeah and it's it's
tricky to blame and here I decided to
give up the h-bond probably the wrong
decision i should play h4b should be to
something like that i'm still okay of
course it's not it's not an advantage
anymore but I shouldn't lose out right
but I was really am a bit confused here
because I lost this threat from from
this almost winning position to to this
nothing position yeah and I need to play
I need to play it with age for just th
form and this is that something that you
can play it's not it's not bad i can try
to i need to coordinate pieces here
which the problem is that those
suspicions are not great maybe i can get
the Queen somewhere here and then
coordinate things that's really better
but I should have taken on Fi
I mean this is this is really a big
mistake not to take Jim he must plane
IDF 64 what else I mean this yeah I mean
this is yeah i can even I can take him
check and this is getting very very
quickly down helm oh yeah really big big
chance that I missed here beating him
beating him again okay thanks for
watching